hey guys it's Anne if you are new here
and you are looking for an active
homeworm farming Community you are in
the right place today my goal is to show
and explain my highest producing worm
bin and there's just the two things that
you need to know in order to have a very
productive bin
I call this the wedge system it's a
little bit modified but we'll go through
that in a little bit and if you're not
new here you're going to see
that blue has an empty spot
which means that I've been doing a
massive amount of harvesting this is
about 10 to 15 gallons of worm castings
that I've harvested in the last
three weeks or four weeks since the last
time you've seen the spin you don't need
a five foot long Barrel in order to have
this kind of productivity you just need
a couple of good tips in order for you
to be successful
so what you're seeing right here is the
overs from when I do my sifting
so these are the ones that are not
exactly
you know finished so one of the things
that I have started doing that is a
little bit different than what I've done
in the past is I have been taking these
overs that are you know hard bits of
stuff that the worms haven't finished
and very likely some warm cocoons that
have gone dormant and I've been putting
these in with my prepared bedding
instead of using the finished castings
and one of the things that finished
castings have that these don't have are
usually some warm cocoons
so my prepared bedding usually ages from
three two to three weeks before I start
using it and that is one of your first
things that you need to realize is that
you need to be prepared
when you are doing your worm bin so
thinking about the end in mind and
basically getting ready
to be successful and harvest as much as
you can in the least amount of time with
your worm bins so what you're seeing
here are seeds and little bits of shells
Etc and bedding that has not fully
composted now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take some of these overs
and I'm going to put those in my bin
with my prepared bedding and I will link
my recipe
uh the video for my recipe up above here
so what we're going to do is we're just
going to take a couple handfuls of this
in a 45 gallon tote with my shredded
paper and coconut coir and this
all of the you know nutrients all of the
bacteria and fungi that live within the
castings as well as the little worm
cocoons in here these are going to
explode into growth once they get into
high moisture and they are going to
start turning that bedding
into castings
before I even use it in my worm bin so
I'm going to grab this and throw it over
a couple handfuls
the exact amount is not
you know 100 percent necessary
scale it to whatever size bin you're
using to make your bedding if you indeed
choose to make your bedding ahead of
schedule
for me that makes a layer about this
deep all the way across the bottom
and so now that we've got our handful of
these overs let's start moving the wedge
down getting prepared
to be successful is my first tip so in
the case of this bed this bin I'm doing
a wedge system which means that all of
the finished stuff is down at this end
it's drier
it has very little food left in it
and the worms actually move out on their
own so as I move this over you can tell
this does have a decent amount of
moisture and it also has some worms in
it
but this is the oldest edge of the bin
so we're going to go through this and
move everything down
so that's what I mean by starting off
with the end in mind my goal here is to
get finished castings now these castings
are probably about five months old maybe
a little bit older
and my goal here is to move them down
here
where I'm not going to mess with them I
might put some air in them by you know
fluffing them up every once in a while
but I'm not going to feed this end and
I'm not going to purposefully give it
any moisture
and in so doing I am going to set this
bin up for success for a fast Harvest so
what I'm doing here is fluffing this up
moving it over
the fluffing part gets all of the air in
there so that it can start drying
so little by little
we're making sure to kind of go in order
so first in first out
anybody who's in manufacturing will know
that as fifo
probably also in retail so first in
first out these are the oldest of the
castings
and I'm very slowly moving them over in
the order in which they had been started
now these castings will start to dry
over the next month or so
the worms are going to start moving down
to the feeding end of the bin
leaving us with castings that we can
Harvest again in another month or so
so what we're doing we're still we're
moving we're getting into like the next
area here this part's probably three
months old
picking out any of the big pieces here
making my life easier when I go to sift
so we'll still just keep moving things
over
I've had a lot of questions about the
wedge lately and one of the things is
that with the wedge and the little inset
diagrams that I put I often put the 45
degree Mark for the wedge
and I don't always or let's just be fair
never
um go in the 45 degree angle
I just shove everything over
the wedge method was originally made for
Barnes
to process like horse manure or cow
manure and when they were doing that
they're not doing it in a nice five foot
Barrel here what they were doing is
they're shoving it off to one far wall
in the barn
and that way every time they clean out a
stall they add something
and possibly at the far end of the wall
they could take something out
what they were trying to do by doing the
45 degree angle was to create air
but in here we have me as the person or
method for
adding air to the system so I don't
really need to do that 45 degree angle
because we're not in a barn
so I am just continuing to scoop here
moving everything over and as I go
around you can see I have a lot more
worms here
but that won't be true for long because
we are going to get to the food end of
the bin and they are going to want to
move into that nice new food
[Music]
okay and I am trying to figure you know
fill this up pretty high because as it
dries it's going to compress
so this bin gets completely fluffed
probably once a month every other month
Maybe
so we're going to
completely move it I haven't done a
harvest this big in a very long time
but needed a lot of castings for my beds
because I've started some new raised
beds recently
and I needed the worm castings
to get the biology going in a brand new
bed and that's the best thing about worm
castings it's not the NPK
it is the biology in here that helps
release all of the nutrients that's
already in your soil I mean the soil
already has
a lot of nutrients in it for the most
part at least mine does here in the
Midwest it has a lot of nutrients but
they're locked up and the biology in the
soil
isn't always sufficient enough
in order to release
all of those nutrients so what I'm doing
is I am supercharging my own soil
so that it can release the nutrients
that I already have
in my soil here getting the sticker out
of here
all right let's move the camera down and
then we will get closer to the area
that's already been fed but we're still
doing the same thing we're moving
everything over so this can dry so it
can cure and so the worms can move
all right hang on let's move over okay
here we are down at the business end and
uh last time I fed an enormous amount of
rhubarb plants because I was tired of my
rhubarb plants not producing
basically I would get some some leaves
and then it would immediately flower I
don't know what its problem was but
quite honestly I don't eat that much in
the way of rhubarb I did offer the
plants out to many people that I know
and everybody already had their own
rhubarb plant
so I did try to give it a new home but
that was not in the cards
so the rhubarb
is going to feed the worms
and as you can see here I have a rhubarb
plant that is still growing
I don't know if we're gonna play
Survival of the Fittest and let this go
you can tell the worms are definitely
working on that root
it's getting all mushy
but we'll move that down hitchhiker
move that down with the rest of the food
but you can tell they're already working
on these big huge rhubarb stems let's
split this open and see if we have
anybody inside and there you go
they love crawling in little nooks and
crannies
for whatever reason you can tell they've
actually got their little castings in
there with them
hey
so still moving
still pulling out the stuff
you can tell oh
much much wetter
much much more worms
oh
looks like they made short work of that
mango seed
take out my label here I had some
radishes
there we go
and this is not super dry
there's like a seasonal problem with the
worm bins I go through a couple Seasons
where it gets too wet when it gets humid
here and then it gets too dry when the
heat goes on
but right now seems to be my sweet spot
it's June
it's 80 degrees in the basement with
about 60 humidity
so everything's pretty stable
okay so let's see what we've got in the
way of finished food
just gonna kind of pick through here and
see what I have and put that off to one
Edge
so like I said
um first things first
you know what is your goal are you
trying to get a whole bunch of castings
well if that is your goal
you need to think about how quickly can
you harvest
and if you set up the worms to get out
of your way because that is very time
consuming waiting for worms to make up
their mind to migrate
so one of the ways that I can make
things go faster is kind of make the
area a little inhospitable
so these worms are going to oh
worm ball in the avocado
I really I wish I knew it was what it
was about the avocado shells that they
just absolutely love all right we will
put the party in the avocado
back
not to you know upset the little Fellers
okay so we're still moving out the
see if we get another worm ball down
here
we have an absolutely massive feeding
for them today
and we are also going to
give an enormous amount of bedding
because I did take out
um three five gallon buckets of castings
out of here so
blue is getting a little skinny
for anybody who's watching that's the uh
[Music]
uh chicken bones
from a project last summer or last
winter
okay
but somebody was asking in one of the
Facebook forums do do worms eat
uh different things and one of the
things that they were asking about
specifically was rhubarb and I told them
uh you know don't tell but
they most certainly do and if you go
back and look at the last video
you will see
how much insane amount of rhubarb that I
put in this bin
okay so we are getting all the way to
the end now this bin does slope a little
bit this way
so you the moisture also kind of
gravitates to that way
there are no drainage holes in here I
manage moisture by
you know adding wet or dry bedding or
wet or dry food in order to mitigate any
sort of problems that I'm having at any
particular time with changing in
moisture
so there we go that is a big old
route that they are getting into
these were completely viable Roots less
than a month ago
and the worms have and they're friends
you've got the little isopods in here
and mites I don't see any spring Tails
springing around but I'm willing to bet
they're there
I usually do have a very good crop of
isopods in here
there's about
15 to 20 pounds
of worms in here so
I get to feed a lot of food so if you're
if your bin is much much smaller of
course you need to get a get an idea of
how much food you should feed in order
to be successful
oops and they have taken apart
that avocado pit
looks like I had another worm ball that
I upended
this one was actually in the avocado pit
all right guys well we'll put you back
the goal is to keep moving the more
finished stuff to this end and the less
finished stuff
to the leading end so that I focus all
of my worms and worm friends
on the food that needs taken care of
I don't like to to leave the food in
multiple different places just because
I want the worms to have one location to
go to so that they get out of my
castings and I can Harvest them ASAP
foreign
and then here is the last
hopefully a little
mostly finished part of the casting so
this is a
a pineapple I don't even know how old
that is I'll have to put that in above
I'll have to go back and look and see
when we fed that
so everything smells great not having
any weird smells but they have totally
annihilated all of that rhubarb that
um
I fed the last time so that's
that's really good good job worms
okay so you can see how
now
all of these worms are here
and when they finally get finished with
all of whatever nuggets of
deliciousnesses in this part here
they are going to move this way
I think that's a potato a little tiny
potato I did Harvest potatoes recently
planted some super early in a grow bag
in the basement and then put it outside
really gave me a jump I was able to
harvest some potatoes
in June so that was that was nice
okay
now the second thing that you need to be
successful is the hardest with worm
farming and that is
figuring out the moisture for the bin
what is too wet what is not wet enough
and honestly
that is something that you have to
basically watch what your bins do in
your own environment and then
write it down in my case I make videos
but basically whatever Cycles you're
seeing within your worm bins and in your
environment you know keep a note of that
so that you can be prepared for it the
next time
so like in the case of right now this is
The Sweet Spot I don't have to attempt
to make it wetter or drier it is
completely managed all on its own but
when we're in the middle of winter
um or in the early spring when it's
super wet then I do have to manage
first things first
I'm going to put a 10 gallon
been of prepared bedding this is pretty
dry and I want to put that on the bottom
so that the food that I'm going to put
on
basically will absorb into this and make
it all nice and tasty so they eat
this has been in the prepared bedding
bin for about a month this part was the
top that dried out in the basement a
little bit and then this part here was
on the bottom and you can tell how well
processed that is now that is because if
you were able to look close enough you
would see that there are springtails in
there and I think I even saw a couple
worms in there
and they get started working on that
bedding so that I get castings faster so
if you keep the moisture correct in the
bin where I keep all of the
the bedding then we go faster and that's
the goal more castings faster
fast uh call on forbidden food okay we
have an onion here
and everything I'm putting in this bin
works perfectly fine bananas nobody's
worried about those bread
you can tell that I soaked all of this
bread in water first
so that it would you know be kind of
like paste if you put it in dry there's
a chance that it will suck the moisture
out of your castings and out of your bin
and it'll kind of turn into a brick
here's something that I haven't done
before so this is kimchi
I uh accidentally left it on the counter
and it molded so unfortunately that
kimchi over there is going to the worms
but I have given things that are
similarly pickled I've put pickles in
the bin before so I'm reasonably sure
that kimchi will be okay just like
pickles were okay
so we've got onions and then we're gonna
give some more pineapple here
lots of bananas here
is a rotten potato that has been frozen
and also thawed mostly
so if there's any questions about this
is zucchini and carrots and here's a tea
bag
um all of these things will be attacked
and will be eaten appropriately here's
an avocado that didn't make it
and they will all just be exactly fine
okay so in order to make sure that this
stays nice and bug free I'm going to get
them some more bedding wait but first
let's add some grit and I'm adding this
generous amount of grit for two reasons
one I have a lot of it it is crushed
eggshell I have somebody in my household
that eats about a dozen a day
so that means a lot of eggshells so even
though the worms don't need this much
grit the garden will use it later so
it's going to be fine so in goes the
next
10 gallon
bin of bedding and again you can wait
wait oh there's a worm okay so for me
putting the overs from my screen into
the bin with the prepared bedding
I'm actually making kind of a miniature
worm bin sort of and uh
so this bedding it's also got some
leaves in it it's got some coconut coir
in it and all of that will make it nice
and fluffy
it'll help make the moisture even
and also this will help keep any flies
or anything away from the spin bucket
number three
foreign
is a little bit drier
but this is going to help so the
moisture will stay down low
and then the dryer part will stay on top
which will keep all of the the bugs from
doing things so I pretty much filled
half of the bin all at once with food
and paper
all of the worms are down here for the
most part and now that this part over
here has food they're going to finish up
over here because this is nice and wet
here they're not going to want to leave
this they're going to stay in here for
another month or two
but down there
at the far end is going to become dry
and they're going to move over here and
then when this starts to dry they'll
move down here
and that way
everything is very simple for me as far
as moisture
dryer
medium
wet
and that is exactly what you need in
order to cycle castings as fast as
possible if you like the video go ahead
and give it a muddy thumbs up if you're
not a member of my worm family click
that subscribe button and if you want to
know what I'm doing when I'm doing it
ring that Bell icon all right guys I
have the playlist for this video right
over here and if you've already seen
that I recommend you watch this video
over here alright guys thanks for
hanging out with me and my worms and
everybody have a good day